c'est toujours notre intention de dabo
les ces clauses de disparité
mais c'est pas
simple il ya un comité qui se penche
là-dessus avec des représentants du
patronat et des syndicats puis j'espère
avoir un résultat une proposition
bientôt j'en ai pas actuellement avec
mme aussi monté laisse le président de
force jeunesse bonsoir bonsoir monsieur
vous interpellez d'ailleurs le premier
ministre pour dire que ça prend une
proposition ça prend une solution il n'a
pas de solution dit il mais il y pense
toujours qu'est ce que vous en pensez
alors tout d'abord monsieur fillon ça
nous rassure qu'elle premier ministre
nouri terre aujourd'hui son engagement
mais on n'est pas satisfait de ça dans
la mesure où comme vous le dis vous le
dites ça fait quatre ans que le
gouvernement s'engage à abolir les
clauses de disparité de traitement et
c'est un plan d'action qu'on attend
maintenant de la part du gouvernement
quand on parle de disparité de
traitement ça veut dire quoi exactement
alors il s'agit de clauses dans les
contrats de travail autant individuelles
que dans les conventions collectives qui
donne moins de droits un travailleur sur
la seule base de sa date d'embauché et
donc sa touche nécessairement davantage
les jeunes avec des clauses qui peuvent
avantager par exemple les les
travailleurs plus expérimentés à
l'intérieur d'une entreprise c'est ce
qui en a encore beaucoup de ce qu'on
appelait communément les clauses
orphelin il en reste encore beaucoup et
selon la dernière demande d'accès à
l'information qu'on a fait à retraite
québec ces 84 régime de travail à deux
vitesses régimes de retraite pardon à
deux vitesses qui subsistent dans les
conventions collectives et ses environs
15 mille jeunes travailleurs et
travailleuses qui sont affectés quand
vous dites 84 régimes de retraite qui
sont touchés par ce dans l'ensemble du
québec dans le secteur privé dans
l'ensemble du québec dans le secteur
privé exact au secteur privé 84 qui sont
touchés quinze mille jeunes qui sont
touchés cela dit en 2018 il ya quand
même une loi qui est passé est adopté
par le gouvernement libéral de philippe
couillard auparavant qui prévoyait quoi
en fait depuis le début des années 2000
les clauses de disparité de traitement
sont interdites pour les différentes
normes minimales du travail prévue dans
la loi sur les normes du travail mais on
s'est rendu compte au fil des années que
des nouvelles clauses sont apparus dans
les régimes de retraite ce qui n'était
pas protégée par la loi alors les
libéraux de monsieur couleurs en 2018
sont venus interdire les nouvelles
disparité de traitement en matière de
retraites mais sans éliminer celles qui
étaient des je dans les conventions
collectives alors ce qu'on demande au
gouvernement c'est de respecter son
engagement et d'aller plus loin en
éliminant celle qui subsiste c'est
faisant de faire ça c'est faisable de
farceurs on pense qu'on y arrive alors
concrètement nous ce qu'on propose c'est
de proposer aux syndicats et au patronat
une période de transition pour négocier
décryptable d'équivalence entre les
régimes pour les éliminer ici à la fin
de cette période le de 3,50 qui nous
semble raisonnable
on n'y arrive pas alors là on imposerait
une solution participe pour les éliminer
parce que c'est vraiment une question
d'équité donnez nous des exemples de
clauses de disparité de rythme alors un
exemple très concret on est dans une
même entreprise parfois des régimes à
prestations déterminées qui sont plus
avantageux pour les employés parce que
la prestation de retraite est garante
sim et des régimes à cotisations
déterminées ou la cotisation et les
prévu est clair mais parce que le
salarié reçoit à sa retraite alors c'est
donc dire que deux travailleurs qui
effectuent la même prestation de travail
ont des versements une fois la retraite
qui varient même s'ils sont dans les
mêmes fonctions comment les entreprises
peuvent passer changer de régime de
prestations à cotisations déterminées
qui en a beaucoup qui ont décidé d'aller
vers la cotisation déterminée est-ce qui
aura pas toujours une forme de
disparités quelque part durant la
transition il est possible de corriger
cette disparité leur faut savoir qu'avec
la loi sur les régimes de retraite à
prestations aux cibles qui a été adoptée
cet automne on ne peut pas passer de
régimes à prestations déterminées vers
un régime à cotisations déterminées on
peut seulement faire l' inverse donc
niveler vers le haut nous on a confiance
que dans le contexte actuel de pénurie
de la main-d'oeuvre mais c'est dans
l'intérêt des employeurs comme des
employés de rehausser les conditions
vers le haut et de d'amener les
travailleurs à cotisations déterminées
vers un régime à prestations déterminées
ou encore un régime à prestations cible
qui aurait des caractéristiques qui se
rapproche le plus du régime à
prestations déterminées bouzid niveler
par le haut mais en même temps en
enlevant les disparités est-ce qu'on
nivelle pas est ce que pour les dangers
de niveler par le bas finalement en
faisant en sorte qu'il n'y ait pas
davantage supplémentaires justement pour
éviter qu'il y ait des disparités
justement on ne les juge pas fait le
gouvernement légiférer sur cette
question là en empêchant la conversion
d'un régime à prestations déterminées
vers un régime moins avantageux donc
cette protection
elle existait déjà maintenant il faut
rattraper cette iniquité leur qui
subsiste depuis plusieurs années et y
régler le dossier pour les quinze mille
jeunes travailleurs qui sont touchés
chez rolls royce canada par exemple qui
sont sans convention collective depuis
mars 2020 les travailleurs dans
l'entretien de moteurs d'avions veut
limiter les mines est ce qu'on appelle
les clauses orphelins du régime de
retraite si le gouvernement va de
l'avant est ce que ça veut dire que les
employeurs se retrouveront obligé
vraiment de les annuler ces clauses là
c'est intéressant ce que vous dites
parce que les employés des rolls royce
actuellement sont en lock out depuis
quelques semaines est la seule question
qui reste pour régler la convention
collective
c'est les disparités traitement si
l'élimination des disparités traitement
alors la proposition qu'on fait c'est
devenu délai maximal au parti si pour
s'entendre pour les éliminer alors
souhaitons qu'il le fasse dans le cadre
de la présente convention collective
mais si jamais il n'était pas en mesure
de le faire on prévoit un délai maximal
pour que les partis s'entendent pour les
éliminer est ce qu'il ya un lien avec la
pénurie de main d'oeuvre ce moment en
fait la pénurie de main d'oeuvre est une
opportunité pour niveler les conditions
vers le haut et les éliminer et c'est un
facteur intéressant les régimes de
retraite pour retenir les jeunes
travailleurs vous avez un pouvoir
supplémentaire absolument et lorsqu'on
demande aux jeunes travailleurs si les
régimes de retraite sont sains comme si
son travail qui est important pour eux
en très grande majorité ils nous
répondent que oui simon te laisses merci
beaucoup d'avoir merci mais c'est fini
pour voir nos émissions en entier rendez
vous sur la chaîne ici et redit
[Musique]